it's so frustrating for me because the
first organization within I think it was
13 minutes that smeared us as racist
bigot Nazis white supremacists whatever
was a Jewish organization in Canada tied
to the Liberal Party called sija they're
the ones who taught who released the
press release on behalf of the Prime
Minister to say that we're white
supremacists now I don't know I didn't
learn much white supremacy in the first
13 years of Hebrew school but but you
know what I did learn we learned about
the Holocaust all the time and this is
where I get so frustrated with these
organizations because from my
perspective what did I learn in all
those years in school Bingo what I
learned was that was the government in
the 1930s that did this wasn't some
random dude you know and that is so lost
amongst people not just the government
it's the point you made earlier and then
the Soviet Union was the same it was the
government getting people brainwashed in
a particular world view and then getting
Ordinary People to tell on each other to
report each other to the secret police
to hand people in for wrongdoing
etc etc and one of the things that I
found incredible during the whole thing
was like my position on all of this was
I'm against mandates and I'm against
mandated vaccination right people are
free to have the vaccination people are
free to wear masks people are free to do
whatever they want right but I think
if you look back the idea that people
shouldn't be forcibly injected with
medical things that they don't wish to
have
came out in 1945 for very good
reason
very good reason and the fact that that
became like a controversial thing to say
no no people came together in Nuremberg
for a very good reason and decided we're
not going to let this happen again and
the fact that people were willing to
just completely Overlook that this is
the thing is they flip everything on its
head like you say
and you know the you know we always hear
about the white truckers in Ottawa and
whatever you know they're all not all
but a very sizable minority maybe even
half of them were from Eastern Europe oh
I bet and you know the last person
standing the last trucker who was
arrested was Chavez
and Chaba is from Romania
and he was telling me I took him to
Boston to to a Bitcoin Freedom uh van
Bitcoin Freedom Festival
and you know I talked on stage about the
Convoy as we just discussed right now
and I handed the mic over to him and
then he brought the audience into tears
telling him what his family went through
uh under Soviet Union control that
the the government was always listening
to them their children couldn't hear
their conversations because if their
children said the wrong thing by
accident in school then you were taken
away you never maybe never see your
family ever the first chapter of my book
I talk about the talk that people would
have with their kids that's right and we
have we've lost all Concept in the
Western World of true how truly bad it
is through this Collective brainwashing
in Academia trying to convince kid I
mean I saw it on campus with my business
that they're oh yeah communism made so
bad really okay so okay go to China just
go go get out of here we don't need you
here leave like if it's so good sort of
thing
um and I know your experience uh you
know I I my heart bleeds for I love
Latin America I really do and I see what
they've done to such a beautiful uh
country and
um I hope they come out of it but we
need to be vocal cool about this and
we're not going to change the world and
better it and Free People if we just sit
back and let it happen some of us have
to speak up which is what the freedom
Convoy was about you know the whole
thing that I found so ironic about covet
is that Hitler was actually against
mandated vaccination he thought it was a
bit too far
he's like no I cannot do this no it's
just too far
foreign